if elon musk is in the news it's usually
for one of three reasons he's announcing
a tesla product that will never
materialize he's revealing the existence
of another child or he's pretending to
buy a company and then backing out well
tesla doesn't have any new products he's
up to 10 kids that we know of so elon
musk now wants to back out of his
purchase of twitter although some
headlines said musk cancels twitter deal
that's not quite accurate musk has
informed twitter that he believes that
the company is in breach of the
acquisition agreement and that he
therefore will no longer perform the
contract by purchasing the company
twitter on the other hand says that it
will sue to force musk to buy the
company at the original sales price so
this raises all sorts of questions can
elon get out of the deal because of bots
can musk pay 1 billion to cancel the
contract and if twitter sues can a judge
force musk to go through with this
multi-billion dollar deal
[Music]
so how did elon musk find himself in
this situation well musk is an avid
obsessed twitter user
in early 2022 musk initiated
conversations with twitter bigwigs and
started buying twitter's stock in
february and march musk accumulated over
nine percent ownership of twitter's
common shares without formally
disclosing his interest in a potential
purchase which was a violation of sec
rules the sec mandates that anyone who
acquires more than 5 percent of the
company's common shares has to disclose
those holdings within 10 calendar days
musk finally signed his filing 21 days
after march 14th the date his stake
surpassed 5
now after accepting and then rejecting a
seat on twitter's board of directors
elon musk made an offer to purchase
twitter for 44 billion dollars after a
bunch of back and forth twitter agreed
to sell if musk could come up with
financing eventually settling on a
purchase price at 54.20 a share which is
entirely possible to be a 420 joke now
for reasons i won't go into musk styled
the deal as a merger with a specially
created company so if you hear the term
merger agreement you can just think of
purchase agreement and on april 25th
twitter and musk announced a joint
agreement quote free speech is the
bedrock of a functioning democracy and
twitter is the digital town square where
matters vital to the future of humanity
are debated musk also said quote i also
want to make twitter better than ever by
enhancing the product with new features
making the algorithms open source to
increase trust defeating the spambots
and authenticating all humans but on may
15th musk started trying to backtrack on
the deal he tweeted that he was putting
the deal on hold because he believed
that more than five percent of twitter's
user base was made up of bots a bot in
this context means an automated account
that isn't linked to a real person now
twitter gave musk more information about
bots but on july 8th musk told the sec
that he was exercising his right to
terminate the contract twitter fired
back that it will sue musk to have him
buy the company so can musk end the
contract or can twitter sue him for
damages well everything hinges on the
contractual language that musk says
gives him the right to terminate the
deal so let's look at the letter that
musk sent to the sec claiming to back
out of the deal and let's look at the
contract provisions to see what rights
are afforded now murders and
acquisitions transactions often involve
the disclosure or transfer personal data
from a seller to a purchaser this may
include all data about the target
company and its assets like data about
employees customers users and
contractors now one point of
clarification here this is not due
diligence due diligence is something you
do before you enter into a merger or
acquisition agreement but in this case
musk didn't do very much due diligence
he signed the merger agreement without
having access to much inside information
from twitter
here musk says that he has terminated
the contract because twitter violated
its obligations to provide him with
access to information that is required
under the contract but crucially this is
not information for due diligence
purposes the time for due diligence is
long over it was over the second that
elon musk signed the merger agreement
but at any rate section 6.4 of the
merger contract is entitled access to
information confidentiality this is the
clause that musk says twitter breached
which states quote upon reasonable
notice the company shall and shall cause
each of its subsidiaries to afford to
the representatives of parents
reasonable access at parents sold costs
and expense in a manner not disruptive
in any material respect to the
operations of the business of the
company and its subsidiaries to the
properties books and records of the
company and its subsidiaries and shall
cause each of its subsidiaries to
furnish promptly to representatives all
information concerning the business
properties and personnel of the company
and subsidiaries as may reasonably be
requested in writing in each case for
any reasonable business purpose related
to the consummation of the transactions
contemplated by this agreement now that
is lawyer speak for twitter must provide
musk with company information and there
are all sorts of caveats it must be
related to a business purpose
query whether musk's requests are
related to a business purpose or to
screw over the business it's hard to say
but musk's legal team has said that
twitter has not complied with its
contractual obligations under section
6.4 quote for nearly two months mr musk
has sought the data information
necessary to make an independent
assessment of the prevalence of fake or
spam accounts on twitter's platform this
information is fundamental to twitter's
business and financial performance and
is necessary to consummate the
transactions contemplated by the merger
agreement because it is needed to ensure
twitter satisfaction of the conditions
to closing to facilitate mr musk's
financing and financial planning for the
transaction and to engage in transaction
planning for the business so according
to musk's lawyers twitter breached its
contractual obligations to close the
deal the centerpiece of the letter is
that twitter misrepresented the number
of bots and refused to give musk
information that would identify the true
number of bots on the platform though
the lawyers couched it very carefully
quote preliminary analysis by mr musk's
advisors of the information provided by
twitter to date causes mr musk to
strongly believe that the proportion of
false and spam accounts included in the
reported mdau count is wildly higher
than five percent now that is not a
factual claim about anything except what
elon musk personally believes which is a
very sneaky way of avoiding an actual
factual claim that could subject the
lawyers to a little bit more scrutiny
and the
musk in general to more liability but
let's hear about it from the man himself
elon went on a podcast to explain that
twitter has so many bots that it makes
twitter a totally different company than
the one he thought he was buying you
know if if they in fact uh have been um
vociferously claiming less than five
percent of faker spam accounts but in
fact it is four or five times that
number or perhaps 10 times that number
this is a big deal um it's not this it
seems like if you said okay
i'm gonna i agree to buy your house you
say the house has less than five percent
termites that's that's an acceptable
number but if it turns out it is 90
termites that's uh
not okay you know it's not the same
house
now if twitter is 90 bots then elon musk
might be correct for reasons that we'll
discuss in a moment but is twitter 90
bots probably not but let's talk about
twitter's obligations twitter responded
to musk by giving him information about
how it estimates the number of fake
accounts
there's a long twitter thread by the
twitter ceo that explains where the
calculations came from he said the five
percent estimate is based on quote
multiple human reviews in replicate of
thousands of accounts that are sampled
at random consistently over time from
accounts we count as mdaus now twitter
claims that its human review process
uses both public and private data like
ip addresses geolocation
and other factors to make a
determination about whether an account
belongs to a real person
musk infamously responded to this thread
with a simple poop emoji because that is
the level of discourse that we
face here
but twitter eventually caved to musk's
demand for more information by giving
him information about every single tweet
in the twitter universe this has been
referred to as the fire hose api a
stream of every tweet that's been sent
this data set includes records of user
tweets the devices
those users tweeted from and real-time
api data and despite receiving this
information musk says that he couldn't
perform the analysis he wanted to which
may not be twitter's problem but his
lawyers identified five more categories
of stuff that they wanted related to
user accounts but the bottom line here
is that twitter probably gave musk all
the data he could reasonably be entitled
to
and the contract probably doesn't
require more of that but there is
another wrinkle here that deserves
discussion because even if twitter
underestimated the number of bots on the
platform musk still doesn't have the
legal right to cancel the agreement
because not all misrepresentations give
musk the right to back out now in a
normal contract a material
misrepresentation
could absolutely give rise to canceling
or terminating a contract but this is a
different kind of contract because
people don't like to enter into these
merger agreements and then have the
possibility of backing out and this
contract would only be breached if the
misrepresentations had a material
adverse effect now the phrase material
adverse effect is a term of art used in
mergers and acquisitions law it's
usually defined in the contract in a
very long paragraph and here the
language has been interpreted several
times by delaware courts we'll talk more
about why delaware later on because
that's the whole thing in and of itself
but in delaware there is a high standard
for showing a material adverse effect
the burden of proof is usually on the
buyer usually material adverse effect is
invoked when the target company starts
having significant performance problems
but even if a company's performance is
in decline and is dramatic delaware
courts generally say that the time
period needs to be measured in years not
just a few bad months and as far as i
can tell delaware courts had never found
a misrepresentation to give rise to a
material adverse effect until 2018 in
the case called acorn versus fresenius
cobby ag the delaware court summarized
the buyer's burden of proof quote a
buyer faces a heavy burden when an
attempt to invoke a material adverse
effect clause in order to avoid its
obligations to close a short-term hiccup
in earnings should not suffice rather
the material adverse effect should be
material when viewed from the longer
term perspective of a reasonable
acquirer in the absence of evidence to
the contrary a corporate acquirer may be
assumed to be purchasing the target as
part of a long-term strategy the
important consideration therefore is
whether there has been an adverse change
in the target's business that is
consequential to the company's long-term
earnings power over a commercially
reasonable period which one would expect
to be measured in years rather than
months the buyer in acorn was able to
demonstrate that the magnitude of the
change in performance was material and
this poor performance lasted for over a
year this precedent probably isn't very
helpful to musk's claim that spam
accounts mean that twitter is
dramatically overstating his performance
in ways that could impact twitter's
profitability down the line in fact one
could argue that if there are uh more
bots than they know of then its
profitability can only go up even
further because he'll get rid of the
bots and make it even more profitable
per user
and this is especially true since musk
said he wanted to acquire twitter to
improve the product by eliminating the
bots the sec filings include voicemails
by musk where he presses twitter to get
the deal done quickly so he can fix the
spam accounts and make the company more
profitable musk then sent a voice
message saying quote if the deal doesn't
work given that i don't have confidence
in management nor do i believe i can
drive the necessary change in the public
market i would need to reconsider my
position as a shareholder this is not a
threat it's simply not a good investment
without the changes that need to be made
so even though musk was at the time the
company's top shareholder he didn't
think the stock was a good investment
unless changes were made he then offered
twitter a share price that was
significantly above its value in other
words elon musk made it clear from the
outset that his interest in twitter had
nothing to do with its current
profitability and he knew that there
were too many bots he said he wanted to
buy twitter to prove a point about free
speech and he said he wanted to make a
better product by authenticating users
eliminating spam and adding an edit
button so to sum it up it looks like
twitter has a pretty good argument that
they gave musk all the information that
he needed and was entitled to and
further twitter can certainly argue that
number one the bot numbers aren't wrong
but even if they were it's still not a
material adverse effect uh if the bot
numbers are seven percent instead of
five that's probably not material though
it's also probably important to note
that one reason that musk and his
lawyers have couched this as a failure
to provide info instead of focusing on
claims of misrepresentation is that the
misrepresentations are covered by the
material adverse effect standard whereas
the obligations of the company found in
the covenants
are generally considered material so if
they breached their obligations on the
covenants they have a better chance of
getting out of the deal itself
additionally musk's lawyers also claim
that twitter failed to run their
business in the ordinary course of
business by firing two key employees and
losing others in violation of section
6.1 of the merger agreement that section
of the contract requires twitter to seek
and obtain consent before deviating from
its obligations to conduct its business
in the ordinary course and preserve
substantially intact the material
components of its current business
organization and this is a very common
term you see in these kinds of
agreements the reason is obvious when
you're buying a company you want to make
sure that that company continues in more
or less the same vein than it started
and it doesn't completely change their
uh their business while you're in the
process of buying it and here twitter
fired its revenue product lead and the
general manager of consumer
and
other employees to it possibly because
elon musk was buying the company
so uh musk said that he objected to
twitter firing many talent acquisition
employees and that he doesn't like
twitter's hiring freeze quote the
company has not received parents consent
for changes in the conduct of its
business including for the specific
changes listed above the company's
actions therefore constitute a material
breach of section 6.1 of the merger
agreement now it is very rare for deals
to fall apart over these kinds of
obligations number one twitter legally
can't force anyone to stay
not since the 13th amendment was passed
and additionally
sometimes as a company you need to be
able to terminate people that happens in
the regular course of business so we'll
see if there's any hay here but it seems
unlikely so let's talk about what's
going to happen in the ensuing
litigation
nothing is certain in litigation but
based on the facts of this case in terms
of the legal arguments i'd much rather
be twitter than elon in this particular
situation now normally when you're
talking about a breach of contract and
contract damages you're talking about
expectation damages the party that
didn't breach is entitled to be where
they expected to be
after the contract was consummated and
you measure that by taking in this case
the promised price subtracting the
current price of the company and the
delta is the amount that would be
necessary to compensate you for where
you expected to be but here the parties
negotiated a bilateral one billion
dollar termination penalty they
considered that twitter might get a
better offer and might want to cancel
this deal so they could go with the
better offer and they also consider that
musk might just you know musk everything
up
but here this termination provision is
functioning like liquidated damages
provision it sets
the damages at one billion dollars now i
suspect that if elon musk could get out
of this deal by just paying a billion
dollars and walking away he would
probably take that deal and just walk
away but here's where things get really
really sticky because section 9.9 b of
the merger agreement gives twitter the
right to sue musk for specific
performance now that is a legal term of
art but that basically means that
twitter can sue musk and it can seek an
injunction from the court forcing musk
to close the deal now that is
particularly complicated here because we
are talking about a deal worth
tens of billions of dollars and it's
also complicated because the deal
requires outside financing from several
banks but the way that those agreements
are written the banks don't have a whole
lot of outs here now in law school they
teach students that specific performance
is very rare and it is courts generally
aren't in the habit of forcing you to do
something that you don't want see for
example the 13th amendment but it most
often happens with real estate because
it's thought that at least legally each
piece of real estate is a unique
thing that can't be compensated purely
by money but when you're dealing with
contracts courts would much rather make
people pay money and go their separate
ways however it happens more frequently
in the context of mergers and
acquisitions delaware courts have been
known to order specific performance in
just such a situation as this although
it's more common for buyers to try and
force specific performance dela reports
agree that sellers in the m a context
also have the right to force the sale to
completion
so this is what happened when a company
called ibp the nation's top beef
distributor entered into a merger
agreement with tyson foods the nation's
leading chicken distributor both
companies performed poorly after the
merger agreement was announced and
tyson's had a buyer's remorse it tried
to terminate the agreement but ivp sued
for specific performance and in
addressing whether a seller has the
right to sue for specific performance
the court found no quote compelling
reason why sellers and mergers and
acquisitions transactions should have
less of a right to demand specific
performance than buyers so the court
concluded that tyson had to go through
with the purchase the court said that
even figuring out the right measure of
cash damages would be too hard since the
amount was presumably huge the court
said that specific performance was
doable since during trial tysons
admitted that it just wanted a lower
price and that the acquisition was still
a good strategy for the company the
court also said that shareholders would
be better served on the whole by a
specific performance remedy rather than
a large damages award that did nothing
but cost tyson a large amount of money
and now i need to explain some trivia
about the delaware courts of chancery
where this case is going to end up
if you've been paying attention to
litigation you often hear people say
it'll take years to resolve anything and
that's usually the case that is not the
case in the delaware chancery courts the
delaware chance reports are basically
business courts on steroids they handle
mergers and acquisitions for breakfast
and delaware made a name for itself by
being the most business-friendly state
in the country and the delaware chance
records have a specific expertise
in dealing with these enormous business
disputes and they are fast this could
end up being resolved in months rather
than years and while the numbers are
very high the dollar amounts are very
high this is not a particularly complex
case uh in fact
elon musk is incredibly online so so
many of the statements that he has made
are
public and will absolutely be used
against him so we'll probably have an
answer to this question pretty quickly
and at base the litigation outcomes are
pretty stark
one billion dollars in damages or force
musk to pay 44 billion dollars to
acquire a company he doesn't want now in
reality depending on how litigation goes
i'm sure all of the parties will
probably negotiate something in between
maybe a bigger fee that lets elon walk
away uh or maybe a lower price and he
consummates the deal it's entirely
possible that everything was just
posturing for him to get a better deal
in the long term or maybe elon never
wanted twitter in the first place who
knows but the important thing is that
lawyers are going to get paid
and speaking of which there is the
breaking news that twitter has indeed
sued elon musk for one count of breach
of contract the company asked the
delaware quarter chancery to enjoy musk
from further breaches of contract to
compel him to fulfill his legal
obligations and to compel consummation
of the merger upon satisfaction of a few
of the outstanding conditions now maybe
it's just me but i find this particular
complaint to be a pretty hilarious
document you can effectively put
whatever you want into a complaint it's
your opportunity to tell your side of
the story and twitter is doing just that
but it also just savages elon musk using
his own statements and fills in quite a
bit of the story and it covers exactly
what you would expect that musk is in
material breach of the merger agreement
twitter alleges that musk didn't uphold
his obligations including financing
public disparagement of the company and
misuses information in the whole you
know backing out of the deal thing
but it also includes interesting tidbits
like musk didn't even read the
information and reports that twitter
gave him even though he's complaining
about not having enough information
and twitter alleges that he can't avail
himself of the 1 billion termination fee
and must specifically perform he must
consummate the deal for 44 billion but
given that this is elon musk this is
only the beginning of the craziness and
you'll be able to read all about the
future antics in today's sponsor morning
brew because that is my favorite way to
catch up with pop culture and the news
i've actually been subscribed to morning
brew for forever it's one of my absolute
favorite newsletters and i'm thrilled to
tell you why because if you didn't know
morning brew is a daily newsletter
delivered monday through sunday it gets
you up to fee on business finance tech
and law in just five minutes and it
provides a fantastic quick survey of the
most important issues while being witty
irreverent and informative it's really
really funny
and did i mention it's completely free
this week i learned all about the james
webb space telescope the continuing
destruction of my stock portfolio and
the continuing destruction of the texas
power grid which apparently doesn't work
in the winter or in the summer now
morning brew is basically exactly the
mix of news that i'm actually interested
in and stuff i didn't even know that i
wanted to know about and it's all
written in a hilarious style morning
brew is one of the few emails that i
actually open every single day so legal
eagles this one is a complete no-brainer
morning brew is completely free and it
takes less than 15 seconds to subscribe
just click on the link that's on screen
right now or in the description to get
morning brew for free and not only will
you get a newsletter that you'll
actually read you'll actually help out
this channel too so click on the link
below to get morning brew right away and
after you sign up you should click on
this playlist for more legal eagle or
i'll see you in court